فتح علمي رائد سرعان ما اصبح قصه نجاح
مبشره لمرضى سرطان الدم من الاطفال
لقد تمثلت اليسا الفتاه البريطانيه
البالغه 13 عاما من سرطان الدم اللمفاوي
الحاد الذي اصيبت به العام الماضي
بعد ان خفقت العلاجات التقليديه من اشعه
كيميائيه وزرع لنخاع العظم في تعافيها
خضعت الفتاه لتجربه سريريه في مستشفى جريت
اورموند ستريت للاطفال في لندن حيث استخدم
فريق الاطباء خلايا مناعيه معدله وراثيا
ماخوذه من متطوع سليم وهي اليه علاج تسمى
التحويل الكيميائيه لاحرف في شيفره الحمض
النووي
بعد اربعه اسابيع من التجربه الواعده لاحظ
الفريق الطبي ان وضع اليسا اصبح مستقرا
مما اتاح اخضاعها ثانيه لعمليه زرع نخاع
عظمي لاعاده عمل جهازها المناعي
وبمضي سته اشهر صار وضع الفتاه جيدا وعادت
الى منزلها مع تلقيها متابعه طبيه
اليسا وهي اول مريضه يعلن عن اسمها
كمتلقيه للخلايا التائيه المعدله اعتبر
اطباءها ان خضوعها للعلاج التجريبي كان
خيارا وحيدا امامها بدل الاكتفاء برعايه
تسكينيه ضد هذا الداء الذي يعد من اكثر
انواع السرطانات شيوعا وفتكا بين الصغار
الانجاز الطبي الجديد الذي يفتح افاقا
مستقبليه واعده جاء بعد تجارب سابقا انتهت
عام 2015 الى الفشل لكن العلماء واصلوا
البحث عن حلول بديله عملا بالقاعده
القائله ان تاريخ العلم هو تاريخ اخطاء
العلم